Hello, everybody. Welcome to another Zoom call.
There are questions came in today, but if you have anything else, make sure you chat down to the status in.
Just a reminder, you'll find any announcements on the members page, home page at the members page, and you could schedule any follow-up visits on the home page as well.
First question, can the chocolate greens first be consumed warm like hot chocolate? Or would this damage the greens?
I think you could... I don't think there would be any issue consuming at times. Now there is some thought of you boiling water.
Of course, when you swallow something, it's quite into your stomach and it's very acidic and it's hot.
So, you know, if you boiled it for a period of time, could you damage it or de-dage it already in the protein or anything? Yes, I suppose.
If you're just putting hot water in it to drink it like hot chocolate, no, I think you'd be just fine with that. I don't see any issue with that, that I could think of.
I think you'd be safe. Next question, what is the best way to get rid of cellulite?
I've noticed I've had more cellulite. I might die in a rear, even over my quadriceps, which were always solid.
I asked because we're working to prevent estrogen dominance, and I know the body stores estrogen.
So, I only need a little maid. So, I only need a little maid, but mostly concerned with story too much estrogen.
In case you don't remember who asked, I've had ER positive breast cancer, which turned 50, so I'm happy with that coming up.
Yeah, there's actually some issues in trying to lose fat too quickly because you made a comment, which is true, in fat cells is where you store most of your toxins and certainly excess hormones.
So, excess hormones are stored in fat cells, toxins are stored in fat cells.
They are the first cell line to pick up toxins and store toxins and hormones.
And the issue has been when people lose weight quite quickly, they liberate a lot of toxins, and they can make themselves quite ill.
I don't think that's what you're asking, you're asking is to how to help fully lose that cellulite, lose that weight.
Well, if I was really good at knowing how to do that really super easily, I'd be very wealthy.
There's a lot of places out there that tell you that they're really good at it, you know, take your money.
The bottom line is just done, is exercising.
Of course, there's reasons why, of course, hold more weight and have a more difficult time losing weight.
That gets into the different hormones, a two-terry thyroid and your three-toband, particularly the thyroid one.
Of course, it has no thyroid and it's even harder than the lose weight that they seem to put weight on.
Also, there's an issue that's left in the brain, which has to do with your feeling of fullness and feeling of hunger with people who gain extra weight.
But as far as just losing that extra cellulite, that extra fat that we all tend to gain as we get older, yeah, there is no real secret to that.
So, it's basically, you know, getting exercise, trying to keep your exercise levels up there, where you're burning your calories that you're taking it as best you can.
Of course, everybody is different, depending on where you're at with your cancer.
There's also genetic factors that play into this too.
Some people are going to gain weight more easily than others. Certainly, you don't love to be in a state of, for kexia or something like that, trying to, you know, you want your best son.
I don't have any secret answers to that.
I went to my local live blood, a presumed live blood analysis practitioner, and he saw signs of oxidation and struggling lip.
He suggested taking diacid, the kind that will make you flush half hour before my son to give it a boost. Are there any problems? Well, you know, I would say they're, they're really already problems with flushing.
So understand if you take diacid and a concentration that's causing a flush.
A flush is, is a rapid dilation of your blood vessels and you actually get this flushing feeling. So if anybody has never experienced that taking diacid, it could actually be scary.
I feel like you could hear like having a stroke or, you know, heart attack or something like crazy is going on.
It is a really weird feeling going through a flush.
And there's actually some articles written that even a person wrote a book about decreasing cholesterol by using diacid by getting.
Flushy diacid, it said the concentration that will cause a flush and open up your vessels. It helps helps dump cholesterol and helps with any cholesterol clacking.
I don't know how well that actually worked.
It's kind of falling off the radar for me as far as patients that we take care of.
But you could do flushing to help with different things that I don't see any issue with it as far as.
But I will make a comment to what he saw with.
I don't know what he was looking at.
Live blood cell analysis is not legal in most states.
I don't know if it was illegal for any practitioner to do live blood cell analysis.
There are been practitioners that were jailed because of it.
Now, that might even make a person think that it's probably there's more validity to it.
But there is a lot of subjectivity to it.
I've taken some live blood classes myself when I was always intrigued with it.
I thought it was always extremely interested in it.
And I actually almost pulled the trigger multiple times getting a microscope.
I don't know if it was myself or the Lord just going to stop to it.
So the issue with it is that there's a lot of subjectivity.
Well, that is the complaint from a standard of care procedure is that it can.
It can be difficult to reproduce objective findings.
And so it takes somebody with a lot of experience.
But you could say that with a lot of different techniques.
It's difficult to reproduce objective findings.
You have to go to somebody who's really skilled and somebody who trust.
So if this is somebody who's really skilled and somebody who really trust it, they really truly did see oxidation.
And it and signs of lip congestion.
I would say there's any problem with doing the diocese and flush.
But as far as the lip oxidation goes.
You actually want to produce an oxidative stress if you're trying to kill the cancer.
So this is remember that.
So you made a common oxidative oxidation was visible.
I'm dried a lot of the slide organized as a.
Private beverage.
Yeah, he has to do some things to protect himself.
So I'm not knocking.
I'm not knocking live blood cell analysis.
I'll just say that.
If he's really good at it, I used to know a guy in Michigan was really good at it.
If I were trust.
And he would do live blood cell analysis and some of the true right conferences.
Here's a great guy.
So.
But it's it's remember you're trying to produce an oxidative state to try to kill cancer.
Because you're trying to increase oxidation of cancer cells.
So I wouldn't do that.
And I said I have a plus to decrease that is you might actually be.
You might actually be seeing the evidence of what you are actually trying to do from a nutritional standpoint.
So.
But.
You know.
Maybe get a check to get and see what he.
What he finds.
I've had to do what I have least wanted to do.
And that is taking a medication that could squally for formal based cancer.
This is what knocks your estrogen levels down.
I was doing great with little side effects due to the protocol.
To less and due to the protocol to less than my antigen numbers.
Have that now raising.
For four months.
I'm assuming that you're talking about your.
Your true record numbers have been rising for four months.
You get the CT scan says that the cancer is stable.
I did a negolace test to confirm one or the other.
How reliable is the negolace test or what other test do you recommend?
So I think like any test.
There's no test is perfect.
So there's imperfection on any test.
So if my.
You know, negolace numbers were stable.
But my.
My tumor markers were elevated.
And my CT scan was stable.
But you got to balance that with how are you feeling subjectively?
Are there any other signs of.
Metastasis.
Are you having any paid anywhere?
Is the CT scan that was done?
Was it a regional CT scan?
Did you look at other places?
Are you done a pet scan?
What are your other blood tests look like?
And what the blood tests.
What are their blood tests that you look at?
Is.
Honestly, as many blood tests as they're willing to do.
Certainly the complete metabolic test.
You're going to be looking at.
The most.
You know, you're going to be looking at liver markers.
Most.
Perfectly.
I would say.
Science, which has to say to bold with liver markers.
Would be elevated.
faculty.
And elevated calcium level.
You're looking.
Looking for science of academia.
And.
Complete metabolic.
So.
Are there any other perfect.
Test to help diagnose.
Cancer.
Reduval scan, that's a whole body MRI scan that is not using contrast eyes if you want
to avoid doing a PET scan, otherwise a PET scan.
So look at some of those things to confirm, you know, the direction of your care, those
are things you want to look at.
I have used frankincense in the past seven years ago for a year with no problem.
But now when I use it on my breast, my breast starts to feel strange sensations and feels
like it's going to leak.
I am using your living brand and by reacting in a negative or positive way.
That's a good question.
So when you have a symptom, you always want to ask, is that symptom, is this a good symptom?
It actually helping kill cancer cells and, you know, it's a symptom that is not pleasant,
but if it's, if it's helping, the overall outcome, then you could say it's a good symptom
or it's a bad symptom.
Well, there's no way that I could know that.
It's very difficult for you to know that.
So one of the things that you can, well, I will say that frankincense can be a hot oil
and frankincense kid, you could easily have not an allergic reaction to it.
Not a sensitivity to it where you could have a sense, a hypers directed.
So it's very possible that that's what is taking place and your body can change even though
you might have put it on directly without a carrier oil, the past, you didn't have any
issues.
Well, now if it's over your breast tumor, where you have a greater amount of inflammation,
you're basically, you raise the threshold of inflammation and now you're causing, it's
tipping over and you're getting skin reactions.
I would think that that's quite possibly what's going on and what you'd want to do to prevent
that is to use a carrier oil.
Even if it's a good reaction, you don't necessarily want, you know, a wound to open up and your
breast to start leaking things like that either.
So you do have to be careful of that.
So I would basically quote unquote water it down using a carrier oil if you want to continue
to use it.
Let's finish these questions here first.
I saw a scientific study on killing cancer cells with frequencies between 100,000 and 300,000
megahertz.
That's a lot of hurts.
Well, over a million hurts, but you might be talking about 100,000, that was the 300,000
hertz.
Using resident frequency therapy device, I will say that there is no resident therapy, resident
frequency therapy device that's close that high.
But you, what's one, early there is a second lower input, all the 11th harmonic, which can
shatter cancer cells, the life capable of doing this.
So the true right is not capable of running 11th harmonic frequencies.
So I think everybody on here today, we look at everybody's names.
Everybody on here today has a true right.
If you've looked at our website, if you've looked at the member site lately, we are starting
to use a different brand of right now as well.
I still love the true right.
I use the true right at home, but I also am using another right machine called the Atelier
Robin P220 machine.
I've always said, and I will always stick to this, that I am not tied to any machine or any
company or any brand or any other outside thing, I'm only going to use what I think is
best for my patients.
So years ago, I used, when I first started using right back in the 90s, we used a B-brain.
And then we added a top of the B-brain, we used a light beam generator and a B-brain.
I don't think true right existed then.
At least, I didn't know anything about true right at that time.
I don't think things existed at that time when I first started using it right.
But when I had the results that I had with my first patient who had bilateral breast cancer,
we used, I was using a B-brain on her and a light beam generator.
So both of them.
So I had two different brands of right now that over the years, I discovered true right
and I followed their machine to be far superior than either one of those.
So I stopped using the beam right and I started using true right.
So that led me to use mainly the true right from that on out.
I still have light beam generators and I used to use it when people came in the office
as a matter of fact, anybody here on the call that came in our office at any particular
time.
We may have done the light beam generator, which I think it has validity of helping move
limp because it's done directly on the skin and it's run or store.
But light beam generator can be a good thing to help with limp flow.
It's a different type of right.
It's not programmable so you can't run it specifically for a specific cancer.
The B-brain I gave up using because it was, it didn't have enough power.
So the true right was about 20 times more powerful than the B-brain.
So I just basically rushed the B-brain.
So it had never been used again.
I used the true right for, then I don't know how many years, 15, 20 years, I can't remember
what I first started using the true right, but honestly.
But lately the true right, though I'm still happy with the true right company, even though
it was bought out by another person, I think they're trying to do things right, but I have some
issues with some choices they're making as well.
So again, back to the droid more, I want to find if there's any other machete out there.
Well, I discovered the Atelier Robin a number of months ago, bought one, started testing it.
It is more powerful than the true right.
Now again, you don't necessarily need more power than the true right because how much power
do you need?
It just has to be able to penetrate your body.
So for that sake, I wouldn't buy an Atelier Robin just because it's more powerful, but
it does have some other benefits to it.
The board that's in the machine allows you to run the 11th harmonic, no, it's funny because
I've never talked about this, and I think I've just discussed it with my staff, the staff
meetings before.
Well, we started to investigate this new P220 machine and there's several things that intrigued
me about the machine and I wanted to test them out and I've been running this one for
a couple of months now, and the running 11th harmonic frequencies have great benefit in
killing pathogens and killing cancer cells.
Now the true right does not allow you to do that, it doesn't have that capability.
So I'm answering the second part of this question first.
So the Atelier Robin has benefits over the true right in that it has more power which
isn't always necessary because it runs on 75 volts versus 30 volts.
Secondly, it has the ability to run the 11th harmonic, which I think is very beneficial
for cancer patients and those that are trying to kill pathogens.
Thirdly, it has a built-in scanner and so the scanning abilities with it are extremely
accurate.
So of course, it could scan themselves and create their own programs.
And then lastly, I think it has a superior foot band apparatus.
So I've been actually working with that company helping another practitioner develop a better
bulb as well, as the bulb, the treatment's opacity of a bulb is the gas that's in the bulb
and the amount of gas that's in that bulb.
So true right, most of you out here have the older true right bulb, that's larger.
They just changed bulbs just in the last year when the bulb is smaller and we're using those
bulbs and we're in the process of developing our own bulb that's larger, it's actually
got a larger diameter on it, it's longer, so it holds more gas and you're going to get
more treatment to be able to be through that bulb because of that.
So there's benefits to the Atelier Robin, would it be like, oh, should I change the Atelier
Robin?
No, I wouldn't say that at all.
My staff has asked that question, should I change in my Atelier Robin instead of true?
I don't know that it's going to, I don't know how much benefit is, you know, again, you
get to this point of how much better is this going to be?
Well, I don't know and it's going to be very difficult to objectively come to any conclusions
about that.
About saying that, well, one of the things that I'm most excited about atelier Robin
is that it allows us to use to run any program using the 11th harmonic and that gets into a
little technicality with frequencies that I'm not going to get into right now, but that
might be what you're talking about.
Actually, there's a video of a scientist who is used 11th harmonic frequencies actually
having up on our website now.
I did have another website for a while because the true I doesn't allow you to do that.
There wasn't any machine on the market that actually that a patient could use that allowed
you to run 11th harmonic frequencies until the Atelier Robin P220.
So now that video is up there was actually a 10 talk a few years ago by a scientist I think
out of the University of Georgia, a 10 talk he did, well, killing cancer cells, he was
in 11th harmonic.
It is up on our website and it's up on the frequency healing site now as well because now
we have a machine that a patient could use that does that.
First part of the question here is using high frequencies to kill cancer cells.
Now, there's no machine on the market that runs that high of frequencies and those that
high of frequencies could actually be very dangerous.
So I would not run those frequencies, but there's a phenomena that it's right frequencies
that you could use frequencies, let's say you wanted to run the frequency of, I don't
say 100,000, right, 100,000 hurts.
Well you could run a divisible frequency from that and get that same harmonic that's dealing
with harmonics too of that frequency.
So you could run the frequency 10,000 at one tenth of that and get the same benefits of
running 100,000.
So that is how right devices work to help kill cancers.
You're not running these super high frequencies that could be cell damaging, but you're getting
the harmonic of that frequency.
I think Mike Tigley, who used to hold true right, did a video on that.
I think we saved it on the right course.
I know true rights scrubbed a lot of his videos, which is a shame, but he did a talk on
running harmonics that I never, maybe I should redo a video on that, but I never did my
own video on that because I thought his video was good, often look and see if it's on the
course.
And I hope that helps you are getting those higher frequencies via a harmonic of that frequency
with the true right, with any, with the true right or the until your Robin, as far as
getting the 11th harmonic, you can only get that with the until your Robin.
I guess if I was somebody listening to this and they're like, well, I don't want to
true right, good to say.
So if you're doing well and your cancer isn't going crazy or anything, there's no way
I would switch.
It's not worth it.
If you were thinking about, if your cancer was getting worse or you're thinking of doing
something different or changing something as far as there because, you know, call our
office and, you know, I will get it to you near cost or something like that.
We'll try to do anything we can if you do want to go that route.
So let us know.
We still sell true rights.
We don't, I mean, understand it's, I have nothing against true right.
We still work with them.
Matter of fact, Jake, the new owner has contacted me to write programs for people who bought
a true right through them.
He wants me to write programs for true right to just to put, because they don't have anybody
writing programs, new programs for them.
So like, remember, you used to update your frequencies because practitioners were sending programs
in, Rodney was writing programs or him when they lost that relationship with Rodney.
And so we may be doing something with that one more than happy to help anybody that anybody
that's trying to help anybody with frequency so, but hopefully that answers that question.
I'll get to your chat questions in just a second here.
My son was diagnosed with bacterial pneumonia.
He's 13 years old.
I declined a chest x-ray, but the doctor said because one lung sounded full and crackly.
And it was likely bacterial, and they are seeing tons of it right now.
They prescribed Z-pack, and I know the holistic world really frogs about antibiotics in
general.
And I always try to avoid the impossible, especially with my children.
I worry about the antibiotics, but also worry about not treating them viral, resolves on
its own, but bacterial is a different story.
What is your opinion about, is this from my son?
Do you think it is relatively safe with few side effects and adverse reactions?
I just don't know what to do.
I value and trust your opinion above all other doctors.
Oh, that's nice.
So I wanted your take on it, and thank God it's Wednesday.
Okay.
I said before that bacterial infections, parts of the U.S.
are playing with for too long.
So you want to look at signs and symptoms.
So understand, if you just go, every time you get an infection, even if a bacterial infection,
if you just go run a get a dead antibiotic all the time, then you're not allowing your body
to go through a TH1, TH2 immune reaction, and that TH2 B cell reaction
is where you make antibodies against the pathogen.
In the past, I remember back in the 80s and 90s, people would run their kids to the pediatrician
for the sniffles, and they'd be given antibiotics like candy.
And the danger of that is the child's immune system never created antibodies to that infection
to that strap or whatever it was.
But that doesn't take place.
Now, you don't have circulated antibodies against that bacteria.
So if you don't have circulated antibodies against that bacteria, well, then you could get it
again, and again, and again, and again, and you have no defense against it.
So there's a benefit to not going and running and just jumping on the antibiotic platform
too quickly.
There's also a risk.
So an antibiotic will kill a bacterial infection.
And if the bacterial infection goes on too long, it could create greater levels of morbidity.
So you have to be the judge of that your child or your dealing with something with yourself.
You have to be judge of your tolerance level and what are you going to be able to handle
this disease.
And if your own immune system is going to be overcome it or not.
So I'm always in favor of, you know, if I feel like I'm coming down with something, and
it could be a bacterial infection, I will try to fight it off with natural things as much
as possible without taking an antibiotic, I haven't taken antibiotics for many things.
Now if my suspect did something like Lyme disease, had a tick, I found a tick, I had a bull's
eye reaction.
I would take an antibiotic immediately, I would not wait, I would not try to let my immune system
fight it off.
That's a whole other discussion.
But in this kind of case, like this, you got to look at the general health of your 13-year-old
if your 13-year-old is super thin and, you know, doesn't have a lot of mass to them to be
able to lose weight during an infection or something, you know, you got to be concerned
about that too.
So, I'm not against antibiotic use.
Side note, if you do take an antibiotic, make sure you take a probiotic with the antibiotic.
There's been plenty of studies out there that show if you take probiotics with antibiotics,
you greatly reduce the negative effects of the antibiotic to the microbiota.
So make sure you do that.
So I can't tell you to take or not to take an antibiotic, but, you know, just knowing those
parameters, my kids got a really bad fever, he's coffee, well, you certainly don't, you know,
want them to get so bad that, that, you know, his recovery time's going to be great, but
you also want him to develop antibiotic.
So it's a balance that you have to work through as a parent.
It's a balance that you work through with yourself.
So I wish I could give you a better answer, yes, or no, for sure, but that would be fair.
Okay, back to the chat.
The diocese was to help sauna with the lip drainage.
Yeah, I think that's great suggestion to take it before you do your sauna.
So you're going to really help detoxification.
I think that's a great suggestion.
Next question, can we use any kind of collagen with the morning shake for joint health?
Now, again, I'm not a big fan of collagen for cancer patients if your cancer is growing
and your cancer is getting worse than when there is some evidence that collagen might not
be the best thing, but if your cancer is stable, it's not going to, I don't think it's going
to cause it to grow anything like that.
I think it's fine to use collagen.
Is it fine to use any kind of collagen?
No, I wouldn't say any kind of collagen.
There's just like good supplements, bad supplements.
There's probably a lot of cheap collagen on the market that's poor quality and maybe coming from China.
So you want to get a good brand of collagen from a practitioner, hopefully, that is buy it from the company.
Nowadays, China is basically, Chinese companies are basically docking off the labels.
They're reprinting the labels.
The stuff you're buying on Amazon would be actually just rice powder.
So next question.
At the conference I was at with Meg, you spoke.
It was said not to use iron skillets as iron is not good for cancer.
I have been taking spirulina and clorella, which has much iron and it constipates me.
I learned these are great for breast cancer, but is the iron produced not worth the health benefits?
Well, I don't think that there's a, I could be wrong, but I don't think there's a lot of iron in clorella and spirulina.
So, but certainly iron hand becomes to pay, especially if it's if it's ferrous sulfate, which is a lot of the iron of the market, which was just elemental iron, which is bad.
So, you know, I don't know, you don't have to look at the bottom.
I don't know how much iron is in those things.
I don't think there's a lot of iron in that.
You know, iron that's in food, like in, you know, different foods.
That's a food based iron that's totally different.
Iron, if you're taking exogenous iron because you have, you know, low hemoglobin, low red blood cells, yeah.
You know, in anemia, you want to, if you're take, have to take iron exogeneously for your anemia, you want to take an iron bisglycinate, a good quality iron that is similar to a plant based iron double bonded to an amino acid.
And I always suggest taking artimistic with the iron because if your cancer cells are goblet of iron, you want them to gobble up the artimistic, the artimistic travels with iron.
So, you know, then cause the cancer so the goblet of the artimistic could help kill the cancer so.
So, if you have to take iron because of an anemia that I would do that.
If you're, if you don't have an anemia, but you're getting iron in just food, then I wouldn't be concerned about that we could certainly take artimistic if you think that the clorella and spirulina has too much iron, you could take its artimistic with it.
But I am not an advocate to use iron skillets as a way to get iron now understand I don't think that if you're using a cast iron skillet you're getting a lot of iron from that skillet as long.
I don't think you are if your iron skillet has been properly, you know, prepared meeting that is it is, you know, got a coating on it of fat which your iron skillet should have if you read it correctly.
And if you're, so you're not getting a lot of iron from iron skillets.
But some people haven't done that and that can be a issue.
I always use a carrier oil, I think you're referring to the frankincense.
Yeah, then I don't have a perfect answer for you.
I don't know if that's a good paid or bad paid maybe just lay off of it for a little bit.
Maybe it has nothing to do with frankincense, maybe try eliminating it for a period of time.
Next question, I have continued to have elevated signature CT DNA tests.
I was taking 18 milligrams of Ivermectin a day, but ran out of the month ago, the CT DNA.
While elevated was going down, the last result said running out of the Ivermectin it went up.
Oh, well, that's interesting.
I was interested in high dose Ivermectin.
Do you at present recommend these types of protocols?
Yes, so absolutely.
And that's a sign that at the 18 milligrams of Ivermectin is not at cancer dose yet, really.
More like 60 would be cancer dose, so 18 milligrams I think would be still too low.
But if 18 milligrams was low or a CT DNA test, then it would be really interesting getting up to something like 60 to see what that would do.
What do you suggest as far as where to go to purchase Ivermectin?
Is there anywhere in the US where you don't need a prescription?
No, I think you do need a prescription. There's places in the US that you can buy Ivermectin.
And they'll have a doctor call you and do a phone thing with you to get Ivermectin.
You can also call the clinic and break and give you a date with a doctor that you might be able to contact to get Ivermectin.
We just talked to somebody else that is a PA that might be able to give scripts for Ivermectin 2, so give the clinic a call.
Yeah, Dr. William Marcus has a bunch of stuff on Ivermectin to the kids are you guys saw his videos and stuff, those are good.
Are there published studies or clinical studies that document results with the right treatment?
And not that I know of there are some studies that have shown the benefits of using the academic field therapies I posted one of them on our website that was published in 2023.
Or colon cancer, there's another one that was published in 2019, a breast cancer, but it'll go specifically into any frequencies, right?
Frequencies to talk to about an academic field therapies with frequencies.
The issue with that is that in order to get it clearance to do a study.
You have to get FDA clearance and unless you're like comparing it with doing it with chemotherapy or doing chemotherapy without it, you probably won't get clearance.
NIH clearance to do a study, so it takes hundreds of thousands to $1,000,000 to do something like that, but I don't propose that they will be anything in the future.
Are you going to know what you have a new bulb? We hope to have it by Thanksgiving, so we hope to have it in the next few weeks.
Right, don't the footpaths allow for higher frequencies? Yes, the footpaths allow for higher frequencies.
That's the other thing that I do like about the interior rabbit is that with the bulb, you can go up to 30,000 birds, whereas with the true right, you can only go up to 12,000 birds.
With footpaths, you can go up to a million with the interior rabbit, with the true right, you can go up to and think about a hundred thousand.
Are you still supposed to update the right programs monthly?
I don't think anything's happening if you do, so I don't think they've had any new programs for over a year, so I don't think you need to do that.
I haven't been since the company changed hands because I thought I heard personal programs may be compromised.
You won't compromise by just updating frequencies, but I don't think there's any frequencies to update.
In Integrative Doctor recommended I do a three day water only fast to reset my system, but said I could have three ounces of bone broth each day.
I made it two days and eight hours, and then was having major crappy diarrhea, and then I looked at this clinic stuff again and realized that you said you should not do bone broth.
What did I do to myself by drinking bone broth?
Well, by drinking bone broth two days, I don't think you did anything, so I wouldn't be worried about that.
But the reason why I don't recommend bone broth for cancer is bone broth.
Bone broth is very healing to the intestinal tract because bone broth is very high in glutamate, so why is glutamate healing to the intestinal tract?
Because glutamate intensifies the growth of new cells.
So you certainly don't want to intensify growth of new cells, but you have a diagnosis of cancer, so I don't recommend people take glutamate supplements or use bone broth.
And, you know, you have cancer, so because we can't do it once in a while, which is, you don't do that on a regular basis.
But I also, you know, I don't have any trouble as you do this three day fast once in a while, but I don't recommend that on a regular basis, just because it has been shown to impossibly increase igia blood levels too.
So typically recommend only a 24 hour fast.
I mistakenly ran the footpath program on my bone for several minutes. Did I destroy my bone?
Well, if your bone still works, you didn't destroy your bone, so don't worry about that.
What should be done for iron overload?
Well, are you talking about you taking too much iron that you should take?
Are you talking about you have excess iron to be a blood test?
It depends on what you're talking about.
So if you have excess iron and blood tests, they'll remember.
The activated Ferris levels does not mean that you have excess iron in your blood form.
So, but of course it did have iron overload.
Iron basically is a heavy metal.
You can use key laders to get that out.
Does the new bulb have different frequency?
And we have to replace what we have now with the new one.
Please, you're not saying you need to replace anything.
So the new bulb does not have different frequency.
It just contains more gas.
So all your bulbs, what a plasma bulb or a Tesla bulb is, it contains a gas.
And then you have running electrical frequencies through the gas.
And now you're getting those frequencies through the light that is produced by that gas.
If you have more gas, you have the potential of getting a greater quantity of frequencies.
Therefore, possibly a better treatment from the same application.
So a larger bulb has greater benefits that way.
So, you know, people have asked me over the years.
Should I get this bulb or that bulb or if it's true, right?
This even with Michael, the company, of course, they make money selling bulbs.
They make money, their equipment company, they make money selling stuff.
And I've said you can buy as many bulbs you want.
But the most part, you really only need to have a bulb.
You're using it at night.
The other bulbs are breakable.
I can't really use it at night.
And, you know, unless you're running a lot of day programs, it doesn't make a whole lot of sense to have these other bulbs.
Well, when TrueRive was bought out, they made their hammer bulb shrink.
So the new hammer bulbs are, you know, probably, or 60 inches smaller.
And I wasn't real happy with that.
But, you know, short of developing our own bulb.
We could really do about it.
So we developed our own bulb.
So, we're going to be selling or going to be larger.
We don't have them yet.
Also, can't buy one yet.
We don't have a modest store.
Hope to have them.
You know, Ronald takes giving time was the proposed speculation.
And it really gave a credit where credit stoops.
I tried to buy Gary Young with the most of work on development.
Really all the work on developing this bulb.
So.
But we've been teaming up with ideas.
So try to just provide the best for everybody.
And that's what our purpose is.
So please, what is the name of the right machine?
The researcher, I couldn't quite get the name of it.
It's called the Atelier Robin.
And we do have information on it on the.
In the right section of the members pages.
Because we have some people on all our new patients that have newly started with us.
Are using the Atelier Robin.
And we have it on our website too.
And it says that we sell both the true right and the Atelier Robin.
So.
I will say if you go to the Atelier Robin website,
you will find very little information because they're not.
They're not a marketing company.
So the Atelier Robin was developed by Patrick Robbins who owns.
An engineering firm.
Making these boards.
And he used to make all of Mike's boards for the.
For the true rights.
Well, when the company was bought, they started getting boards for another source.
And.
And now.
Patrick Robbins.
And.
And a few other people started developing the right machine.
So as far as dispel it's ATEL IER.
Atelier, the second name is Robin R.O.D.B.I.
And again, you can find information on it on our website.
On the member site.
To the right information on the frequency healing site.
I have videos on it.
And information on it is there as well.
If you go to the Atelier Robin dot net website.
He's from Canada.
He in the website is very antiquated.
And it's just.
There's not much information there.
So.
He only really sells into practitioners.
Okay.
Any other questions.
But I will let you know what the do bulb is available.
I don't.
I don't think there's that much difference in the treatments of let's say if you have a.
You know with it.
thighs is gonna come to me here.
I'm just like, not on the, certainly.
Pretty much mommy said it.
I didn't know.
The.
Curve to Christ the current newer smaller crystal hammer balls,
should you get these new bigger one?
I would say.
Again. No. About.
It's, you know, my hope that there'll be even any slight difference in slight improvement in our outcomes.
You know, I'm willing to take that and I'm willing to, to risk, um, you know, losing a relationship with a company, if it's going to be better for our patient.
So it's all about you guys.
It's not about me pleasing some corporation of it.
So if I only knew about the new machine, I wouldn't have bought the right, um, well, then you would have been a big people because the new machine just came out a few months ago.
So there was no new machine before a couple of months ago. So, um, you would not have a machine. So, um, in plus you got taking what I just said about it right now and put it on your stock in it.
Um, I just, I'm just telling you, you know, I'm doing always what's best for the patients.
The new supplement comes out that's better than our private label supplement.
I mean, we change our private label supplement to that that you don't need enough this far in time that that's all we care about.
Offending some supplement company because we've just changed off of their private label to a different one.
It's about what's best for our patients. So, um, I hope you, you trust what we're doing is always for you not for money or for some companies, please eat some company.
You know, you're actually somebody else's plan. So, all right.
Um, everybody have a great day and we will talk to you guys next week.
Thank you very much. As always.
Oh, absolutely. Hopefully I didn't just confuse people talking up the machine, but I hope it'll be a blessing to everybody.
Bye bye.